it's a fantastic movie obviously it's a
zombie movie anyway how does it stand
out from all those other zombie movies
out there well there's some pretty great
zombie movies out there out there to me
it stands out in that it has a real kind
of emotional undercurrent I think
there's a lot of great action zombie
movies there's a lot of great there's a
lot of great funny zombie movies too
like Shaun of the Dead is an amazing
movie I think one of the best movies the
last 20 years but there's something
about being able to see a zombie story
from the zombies point of view like what
it feels like to go through that also
what it feels like to I played the
parents of a zombie movie so it sort of
takes you through what it feels like to
lose a child and then get it back and
this crazy emotional rollercoaster that
a lot of the characters in the movie go
on kind of a strange world it doesn't
happen in real life isn't it a bit like
another movie that you've got coming up
this year guardians of the galaxy how
was it shooting that movie oh it's great
he got to be in London other than that I
think Marvel will put me in handcuffs if
I say another single word about it but
yeah compare making an indie movie like
life after beth to like a huge special
effects movie like God into the galaxy
you know I think all the best movies
that I've been involved in I would
consider independent movies whether they
cost 150 million dollars or whether they
cost fifty thousand and independence
comes with the vision of the director
more than the size of the budget you
know like I worked on the perfect storm
with wolfgang petersen and I've he's one
of the most independent minded directors
have ever seen no one was telling that
guy what to do he made that story
exactly as he saw fit so yeah and then
ever worked of course a lot of films
that I brought here to Sundance with a
lot of people just starting out and
yeah so independence is not a budget
dependent life after beth your
daughter's played by Aubrey Plaza who
looks a little different we normally see
her differently as the zombie bear you
want some working within gorgeous a
galaxy people like those are Donna as
well he looks a little different we
normally see here as well as the
green-skinned alien I mean what's it
like working with those guys and and how
do you kind of look at them a bit
differently when you're on set with it
when they look very different than you
normally expect them to well it's funny
I've played characters that extreme
looks before too and I think what
happens with actors you just forget you
forget what you have on your face
because you're just looking out through
your eyes of course and yeah working
with Zoe I had never I've still not met
her and I think on the last day I saw
her without her makeup on so I only met
her one time with when she wasn't the
color green and I was like you're
beautiful she's like thanks but uh yeah
you know when you're behind the curtain
as it were you just quickly get used to
you know someone's got a bloody stump
for a handy like oh yeah that's this
must be seen 13 we're doing today like
Jodi's movie speaking to you thanks so
much
you